[Music]
here is some dramatic news from
Hollywood writers are on strike and
numerous films and series are at risk
plus there's another comeback for
Deadpool 3 and news on Elita battle
Angel 2 another prequel to Transformers
and the animated the Lord of the Rings
feature film welcome to keynotech news
just recently new posters and a new
trailer for the upcoming Transformers
rise of the beast surfaced in addition
to the long-awaited action Blockbuster
an animated feature film is now also in
production as Paramount disclosed last
week the casting choices in particular
have attracted a lot of positive
attention the movie titled Transformers
1 will reportedly be a prequel to the
movie series together with director Josh
Cooley who among other projects directed
Toy Story 4 those responsible want to
produce a different kind of film
Transformers 1 is to be an animated
movie after having told the story of the
Transformers on Earth in numerous live
action films the new project aims to
shift the focus to the origins of the
mysterious machine beings there were
similar ideas a few years ago as
producer Lorenzo D bonaventura revealed
in an interview with collider at that
time the main obstacle to an ambitious
live-action film about Optimus Megatron
in their younger years was way too high
budget exactly this problem could be
avoided with an animated film as the
production is significantly cheaper than
with lavish action scenes and costly
explosions on a physical set so now the
story of Optimus Prime and Megatron is
being adapted into a new format and we
already know who will be dubbing the
main characters Thor actor Chris
Hemsworth will give his voice to Optimus
Prime while fellow actor and Atlanta
Star Brian Tyree Henry will dub Megatron
with Jon Hamm Keegan Michael Key
Lawrence Fishburne and Scarlett
Johansson many other Hollywood stars
have also been cast the theatrical
release for Transformers 1 is currently
set for July 19 2024.
Deadpool is without question one of the
most popular anti-heroes in the Marvel
Universe the hype around the third part
of the film series already exceeds that
of the two predecessors which is also
largely due to the appearance of Hugh
Jackman as Wolverine in addition to the
two main characters some other
characters will make their comeback and
as we know since this week among them is
a real fan favorite from the second part
as deadline reports the talk is of
X-Force member Peter who was embodied by
Rob Delaney
thing about his character is the fact
that Peter doesn't have any superpowers
and thus stands out from the other
members the very fact that he is
actually just a normal average guy made
for some funny scenes in the midst of
the superheroes for example Peter
miraculously survives a parachute jump
in Deadpool 2 while many of his
colleagues perish in spectacular fashion
a little later however Peter also dies
after he is accidentally covered with a
toxic substance during a rescue attempt
this is reversed at the end of the film
by Deadpool's time travel where he warns
Peter of the danger and thus saves his
life already through this action it
became clear that Peter could make a
comeback in an upcoming film indeed
according to deadlines report actor Rob
Delaney is returning and negotiations
are said to be cut and dried whether
Peter's screen time will be longer this
time than in the previous film is still
unclear and so is the question of the
importance of his role for the plot of
Deadpool 3. in addition to Delaney also
returning are Karen Sony as Defender
Stefan capichick as Colossus Leslie
uggums as blind Al and Miranda Baccarin
as Deadpool's lover Vanessa behind the
scenes things are less consistent as
director David Leach will not return for
another installment instead we can look
forward to the directing of Sean muddy
who directed free guy and other films it
will still take a while until the
theatrical release of Deadpool 3 the
film is not scheduled to be released
before November 8 2024.
fans around the globe are eagerly
anticipating a sequel to 2019's Elita
battle Angel and not just because of the
major Cliffhanger at the end many
viewers were particularly excited by The
Peculiar look of the Sci-Fi action
thriller after years of Silence producer
John Landau has now commented on a
possible Sequel and what Avatar 2 has to
do with it with James Cameron's Avatar
the way of water the cult director not
only succeeded in making the world's
third most successful film of all time
but he also created a visual Masterpiece
as and I'll revealed to Screen Rant
Elita battle Angel also played a huge
part of this as a top of filmmakers a
lot about subtle facial expressions and
how to Stage them by the way the
fruitful relationship between the two
film Series dates back far longer
because without avatar from 2009 I'll
leave a battle Angel would probably
never have been made after the great
success of Avatar the way of water it is
now again time for the franchise around
the battle hard in Elita to benefit
preparations for Elita 2 with returning
director Robert Rodriguez are well
underway and apparently lead actress
Christopher Waltz and Rosa Salazar are
also said to be showing interest in a
comeback whether Avatar Creator James
Cameron is also involved as a producer
is highly unlikely due to his commitment
to Avatar 3. how things will continue in
terms of story is still the subject of
speculation at the moment considering
the end of part one it would be quite
nice to take a look into the past of the
protagonist a classic Revenge story is
also imaginable we can probably expect a
combination of both it will certainly be
exciting to find out how exactly Elita
battle Angel 2 will benefit from Avatar
the way of water we will keep you up to
date about further news
[Music]
the Amazon series The Lord of the Rings
the rings of power is far from being a
great success for the streaming provider
despite major criticism the second
season of the most expensive series of
all time is currently in the works and
they are trying to turn the tide one
more time in parallel the animated film
The Lord of the Rings The War of the
rahiram is breathing new life into the
cinema as reported this week you can
already look forward to a first
impression long before the official
release in mid-june the international
animation Film Festival will take place
in Anise France and it is said that
first scenes from the movie will be
shown there it is likely that we can
also expect the release of a first
teaser trailer in terms of story the
focus of the Lord of the Rings The War
of the rohiram is on the war of the same
name which has decisively shaped the
history of Middle Earth and prepared the
basis for the film Trilogy by Peter
Jackson especially the Fortress
helmsdeep and rohan's King Helm
hammerhan are likely to be the focus the
latter will have to take on his
adversary the dunlanding board won't in
the course of the story due to the
realization as an animated film we can
look forward to particularly spectacular
scenes after all animated films have
fewer limits than live action ones which
would require a lot more effort and
money actors from the trilogy will also
be involved in the animated films for
example Miranda Otto who embodied aeon
and now acts as her voice actress has
joined the cast we are looking forward
to the reports from the international
animation film festival and hope to have
more information about the Lord of the
Rings film The War of the rohiram soon
the theatrical release is currently set
for April 12 2024.
Hollywood is in an uproar The Writer's
Guild of America the wga has called a
strike on May 2nd the powerful
Association includes most of the
screenwriters in the American film and
television industry an ongoing strike
can have a major impact on current and
future Productions the strike is
basically about writers wanting more
money for their work especially if their
stories turn out to be a huge hit in
streaming other issues include secure
employment and the Banning of artificial
intelligence in the writing process the
wga has been in negotiations for six
weeks with various providers such as
Amazon Apple Disney and others according
to Insider Jeff Snyder the talks are
rumored to be failing mainly because of
Industry giant Netflix which
persistently refuses to offer authors
better conditions the last major writer
strike in the U.S is still fondly
remembered by many today in 2007 members
stopped working for 100 days in order to
obtain better working conditions the
consequences were felt by both the
industry and viewers many TV series were
canceled or shortened here Rose and
Pushing Daisies for example met an early
end while the first season of Breaking
Bad had to be Rewritten and ended after
just seven episodes many like Ron
Howard's Angels and Demons were
postponed by more than a year at that
time TV stations increasingly relied on
reality formats which was simultaneously
accompanied by a decline in viewing
numbers many also complained about a
later noticeable loss of quality in many
series because often inexperienced
writers had taken over the work of
striking colleagues in addition to the
long-term consequences not all of which
can now be 100 proceed the current
strike is already having a direct impact
popular shows like Saturday Night Live
The Tonight Show Jimmy Kimmel Live and
many more had been paused indefinitely
in the midterm the strike may also
affect season premieres of series that
will be released starting next fall and
are currently being written or maybe not
anymore particularly at risk are some
future theatrical Blockbusters currently
in pre-production depending on whether
work on the script has already been
completed there is a possibility of
delay days or compromises in production
here these include a Sonic 3 fast and
furious 11 or I Am Legend 2. only
recently plans for the next Star Wars
movie by James Mangold taika waititi
Dave filoni and Charmin obey chenoy were
finally specified now any further
development of the materials must
probably be paused for the time being
fans of superheroes must also fear be it
DC's the Batman 2 Superman Legacy by
James Gunn or Marvel films like
Fantastic Four Avengers the Kang Dynasty
Avengers Secret Wars or the blade reboot
they could all be effective the release
of Deadpool 3 Venom 3 and Spider-Man
beyond the spiderverse could also be
delayed in case the strike interferes
with script development according to
Jeff Snyder the strike is expected to
last about 30 to 45 days naturally the
actual situation could also last longer
or just end sooner we hope for a quick
agreement between all parties for the
sake of both the authors and US fans so
that the whole thing does not have too
big of an impact on future films and
series
after all this news it's time for some
excitement in our latest Keno check
Originals we've gathered all the
information you need to know about
Inside Out 2 and Kung Fu Panda 4. check
out the videos and let us know what
movies you're looking forward to the
most thanks for watching and see you
next week for more Hollywood updates
[Music]
thank you